so now let's swing over to the televised
mental institution known as MSNBC here
is a guy named Ryan Reilly never heard
of him before but he's I guess a
contributor over there and he's very
upset that the Biden Administration is
not going to be able to censor you as
much as they once could
have to say the administration will
eventually appeal this I think that's
pretty safe and I think that that's
where the worry is in terms of
communicating uh with social media
companies about ongoing threats in the
national security threat he creates sort
of a carve out for that but essentially
what a lot of these allegations have to
do with is the government flagging posts
that violate the standards that these
social media companies have
independently set up so if they find
something that you know they're flagging
this post and say hey this they're not
explicitly saying you need to take this
down often they're sort of an implicit
implication there if saying just you
know bringing this to your attention and
then the social media company can decide
independently whether or not that
violates their ongoing standards but I
mean it's a really new area and a really
complicated one and one that there
should be close guard rails on to make
sure that the government is not
overreaching but the idea that the
government can't have any communication
with these social media companies I
don't think it's something as a really a
world that we would want to live in
what an absolute tool dude I don't want
to live in the world that you want to
live and you want to live in a
sensorious world what he's saying there
is the mafia move is okay first off what
right is it let's say there was all
sorts of misinformation on every social
media platform right now and guess what
there is right people lie all day long
they now with AI images and there's
going to be AI video and voice and all
of the stuff and memes and and just
everything it's it all exists right now
do you think the government should be
coming in and silencing people for that
will that make anything better of course
the answer is no but then when he says
this thing well you know they didn't
really Force anyone to do anything they
just contacted these guys just to tell
people oh you know Facebook uh some of
these people are doing things that are
against your own policies over there
I've always described this as this is
the ultimate Mafia move what does the
mafia do what does the mafia do when
they want to extract a price right they
walk into your restaurant and they go
boy this is an awfully nice restaurant
you got here it'd be a shame if
something happens to it so they didn't
just walk in and shoot you dead but they
told you you are going to behave the way
we wish that you would behave otherwise
something might happen to your
restaurant or something might happen to
your big tech company the fact that this
guy and these ideas are put on
mainstream media to to put the Nugget
into some NPC who watches MSNBC or any
of these channels to put it in their
head that oh yes well I guess I wouldn't
want to live in a world where I couldn't
be censored by the government big Tech
who what am I what am I some sort of
thinking automaton come on
[Music]
thank you